In order to think about starting to
understand color in a standard way,
experiments were done and
they started quite a long time ago,
where you'd do the following, right?
You would, you would make some
light coming into the observer, and
that would be some light
along that spectrum.
So, the red, the green, the blue, etc.,
you'd have some pure spectral light.
All right.
And the observers job and here the
observers one great big eyeball which is
kind of creepy, but
there's actually a person sitting there,
would be to just adjust the amount
of red, green and blue light.
And they were given a particular
type of red, green, and blue,
particular wavelength of light, and they
could put more or less of it, of each of
them to try to get it to match the test
light that was being produced.
And most of the spectral
colors could be done this way.
You could just add a certain amount of,
of that light.
But, it turned out that some of
the colors couldn't be matched,
unless you actually added, a little bit
of red to the original test light, okay.
That is, in some sense, in the mixture,
you had to sort of like have negative
red light and of course we
couldn't make negative red light.
So what you would do is you would
sort of add some positive red light to
the testing.
So that's the first thing to
realize is that certain color,
certain wavelengths in the spectrum.
You would look at it and, you know,
for those particular three lights they
gave you, there was no blending of them
at all that would equal this color.
And the way that gets expressed
is the following, right?
So here you were giving
a certain type of blue, green,
and red light and then depending upon
where you are in the wavelength, where
you are in the spectrum, depending upon
what single light I put out, all right?
You would have, this is how much red,
green, and blue you would need to add,
and you'll notice this
area here is the negative.
These were the colors, okay?
These were the spectra that for
those particular red, green, and
blue lights that they gave you,
you couldn't make them match.
So they represent that as
being sort of negative red.